did you find the quicksand beat on
youtube
hell yeah no you just found the beat on
youtube what what did you type in on
youtube like what type beats did you
type in to find it because everyone
types in like
something type beat no cap i put um what
i put smoove hip hop and r b and it
popped up
it popped up i was like what the [ __ ]
and there was a um
it was a type b oh [ __ ] was it
a roddy type beat roddy rich type beat
it really was
ronnie richardson like somebody else
right x somebody else or what it was
i think you're hard as [ __ ] when i was
yourself i guess your heart i'm like let
me see if i can
do my [ __ ] on the [ __ ] and then
it just it just i already cause i have
wrote some of the lyrics without the
beat
right i was in my feelings i was just
writing
and i was like this beats how to go
crazy
okay hold on hold on i can't it can't be
like that i started over kept writing i
was like
no cap i'ma use this beat i download
that [ __ ] you two mp3 [ __ ] somebody
did what it
exists is that there and i got that beat
use that [ __ ] hit them up like bro i
want to buy the beat
did you buy the beat before it was like
huge yeah yeah just how much was the
beat original i have no idea
but it probably went a lot i don't think
so probably a couple hundred dollars or
something maybe
i don't know a lot of those youtube type
b two i mean you could lease them
mm-hmm hey this song probably changed
that guy's life too
no cap hey i think his name was um aunt
chamberlain
yeah look him up bro he got some [ __ ]
[ __ ] real rap hey that youtube [ __ ]
is real
nope it's some fire youtube producer
[ __ ] they actually
no cat